[Music]
one of the factors of late modern life
that philip k dick discusses in the
android and the human has to do with
drug use and we can understand drug use
in several different ways drugs are
products he's definitely going to talk
about that there are also things that
human beings administer to other
human beings or that human beings may
self-administer take on and say this is
going to be good for me and he talks
about two different kinds he talks about
what he calls street drugs and we could
call these the drugs of entertainment
that people are using they get bought
and sold as commodities and then there
is the drugs of greater concern what he
calls establishment drugs now obviously
there's going to be some overlap between
these when kids steal some older
person's medications or older people do
this with kids as well and take them
in order to like sort things out in
their life or in order to party have a
good time have some sort of experience
there is a significant overlap there and
we could also talk about establishment
drugs where they're not doing exactly
what dick is afraid of think about
opioids which were you know over
prescribed in many cases illegally and
immorally producing an entire opioid
epidemic which then
couldn't be
met
the needs of which couldn't be met all
the time by the
pharmaceutical
industry and the the doctors who are
doing it so people would go to street
drugs to get that same sort of high or
relief from the pain that they were
experiencing so there is kind of an
interplay between the two of these but
dick talks first about
street drugs and he says they are a
major problem in the area where i live
and what is you know the
the major problem
he says the illegal drugs you buy on the
street are often not what you think that
you're getting so they can be
cut or adulterated or just plain not
what you're told that they are and then
what happens well you wind up poisoned
or dead or just plain burned which means
that you don't get off which means you
pay ten dollars for a gram of milk sugar
and then he tells us something quite
interesting
about this is sort of a side or
digression he says you know
labs are
set up free labs for the specific
purpose of analyzing street drugs you
mail them a portion of the drug you've
bought and they tell you what's in it
the idea being of course if it has
strychnine or film developer flash
powder in it you should know before you
take it so it's sort of like a consumer
protection right
if you're buying these illegal drugs and
somebody's likely been cutting them with
something you can find out what it is
and then don't take it or take it at
your leisure
but he says the cops saw through this
right away
and the drug manufacturers
kind of like it as well he says
they act as quality control stations for
drug manufacturers let's say you're
making methadone in your bathtub at home
a complicated process but feasible every
time a new batch comes out you mail a
sample to one of those labs for analysis
and they write back no you haven't got
it quite right cook it for maybe five
minutes longer this is what the police
are concerned about the police are not
actually concerned you know from dick's
perspective about the dangers to to
people from the street drugs they're
more concerned about
quality improvements in these and he
says the drug pushers also are kind of
for this the pushers are doing precisely
that seems kind of a nice idea the
pushers being interested in what they're
selling back in the old days they cared
only that you lived long enough to pay
for what you purchased after that you
were on your own so there's a kind of
benignity or benevolence on the part of
the drug dealers not a real one of
course but
dick goes on and he says that there were
lots of issues that resulted from the
use of street drugs which were viewed as
something kind of liberationary you know
you could have new experiences you could
go against the system by not doing what
they wanted you to not feeling what they
wanted you to right
but
as he saw it led to a lot of suicides as
he says psychosis
organic irreversible damage to both
heart and brain i think it's kind of
interesting that he says heart and brain
here rather than
body and brain
and or you know some other organ you
know the drugs can also affect your
kidneys or your liver
he talks about the heart i don't think
here that the reference is simply to the
organic
tissue that we call the heart rather
it's to
our personality
because he goes on and he says um you
know
these these are a menace uh you at one
time you may have read this in
biographical material accompanying my
stories and novels i was interested in
experimenting with psychedelic drugs
that's over for
me
why well because
he saw the effects of it and if you want
to get a solid sense of this there's no
better novel than a scanner darkly where
dick at the very end
talks exactly
about what it is that he experienced and
saw of much greater concern to him
though he says in this this piece are
what he calls establishment drugs
and you know at any given time
america is just flooded with what we're
calling establishment drugs and he says
that these are reputable prescribed by
reputable doctors
uh given in reputable hospitals
especially psychiatric hospitals and
then he says
these are
pacification
drugs
now what does he mean there
they
change the person to make them more
amenable or less of a bother or to fit
in better or more productive and we
could think of all sorts of drugs that
have come on the market since the time
of dick you know
drugs that allow us to focus better
drugs that even our affects out
and so he he goes on and he says i'm
thinking that they actually produce
soul damage and i've got to explain what
i mean by soul
damage
so he says that
it's been discovered recently what we
call mental illness or mental
disturbance such syndromes as the
schizophrenias and the psychothymic
phenomena of manic depression may have
to do with faulty brain
metabolism now i also like this
formulation he doesn't say they
stem from they are
caused by he doesn't use reductivist
language like that he says they have
something to do with that is there is
definitely a connection because you can
give people drugs and see that they
stop having hallucinations or they stop
acting in the way that they were they
report
having perhaps more clarity or less
intrusive thoughts right and so he says
you know
brain catalyst like serotonin
noradrenaline
these things you know might not be
present in in the right amount
and um he goes on and he says he gives
some examples of of things that can lead
to these problems so he says mental
illness then is a biochemical phenomenon
if certain drugs such as the
phenothiazines
are introduced brain metabolism regains
normal balance the catalyst serotonin is
utilized properly and the patient
recovers and we could go over example
after example
like this and then he says
by the way there is a drug of choice
these days
it's it's not used quite as frequently
now i think as it was in his time he
talks about lithium carbonate and you
know generally just referred to as as
lithium and if you've ever seen
people given too much of this
it is quite a frightening sight the
transformation that comes over them and
many people who take lithium report that
particularly for a bipolar disorder as
these calling it manic depression
they report that it works for them and
it works for them by
flattening everything out the highs are
gone
but the lows are gone
and it's
you know it's a question of whether
that's a
good trade-off he says if taken by the
disturbed patient lithium carbonate will
limit an otherwise over-abundant
production or release of the hormone
noradrenaline which most of all acts to
cause irrational thoughts and behavior
of a socially unacceptable sort
and then he says the entire amplitude of
feelings wild grief anger fear any and
all intense feelings
will be reduced to proper measure by the
presence of the lithium carbonate in the
brain tissue what are the results the
person will become stable
predictable not a menace to others he
will feel
the same and think the same
pretty much all day long day after day
the authorities will not be greeted by
any more sudden surprises emanating from
him and this goes directly to what dick
had talked about midway through this
section
he is concerned with
drugs
causing a reduction of the human
to the android
he says
i mentioned these pacification drugs in
order to return to my main preoccupation
here
the human
versus the android and how the former
can become can in fact be made to become
the
latter and this is what he's talking
about is soul damage the reduction of
the human
down to a lesser state
the
not non-human but the
android because the human is still the
basis for all of this and there's a
danger in both of these types of drugs
of that happening a greater danger i
think you know on his his view uh with
the
drugs that are prescribed the drugs that
are legal the drugs that are part of the
fabric of normal society but i should
point out that street drugs if you read
his a scanner darkly he uses
language of human beings being reduced
to stimulus response machines to insects
to having that sort of
reduction
of what it is that makes them human a
loss a permanent loss in most cases and
so dick thinks that drugs could in fact
serve some useful purpose he's not
throwing them out entirely
but he thinks that we have to be
very very careful
in how we approach them
and
make use of them
and that they are in fact being used to
control people
to reduce them from the human to the
android
you